oh my god
Donald Trump has been getting whacked
around a lot these days at parties and
protests he's the hot pinata of the
moment in the US and Mexico I even
brought that to his attention last alive
there are truck pinatas being hit right
now what he thought about that but again
we decided to travel across the border
to Tijuana to find the Mexicans who are
turning the candidates racist rhetoric
into cash before then they go for the
bunny turns out Chum pinata sell out
pretty quickly here
we checked with six shots before
stumbling upon dose Andrea Ayala which
had just one left money or just a left
on the drum in number una which was the
NNI umbrella for a super discreet Asuna
poor mother River dipped in brothels for
more
while carrying the Trump pinata down the
street I got a taste of how some
Mexicans really feel about him of course
the most memorable moment came from this
woman my next stop was the home of one
of the few families in Tijuana that make
Trump pinatas Manuel and his wife
Johanna have made almost 2,000 Trump in
Yoda's over the past six months
Yuriko
this place is Parekh is a sacred opening
up at the lawn Sacco Munakata
mm-hmm equates there is no processes a
tiara or now this is the Yummie
signature this is yummy favorite men
well his brother and wife worked ten
hours a day making these piñatas the
most popular Disney Princesses Trump may
lack their charm but he's in high demand
- the more he dominates the headlines
the more money this family makes its
business as Manuel says although he
clearly has some feelings about the
presidential candidate finished